hello and welcome to this video coverage
of the second round off the 2017 top of
steel tournament the second round had a
little bit more on action than the first
one first round only had one decisive
game and the second one actually had
three so we're going to look at those
three designs of games of course the
drawers and also should be checked but
they weren't all that exciting the only
game that had some yeah we'd looked like
the could be a winner was report with
one against kayaking report played one
of his usual usual unusual since opening
so to say played one be three and got
into a bit of trouble that defended well
I think and made a drawing and kayaking
so let's look at the decisive aims first
one the Indian do will have a trishna
with wine against audubon got a ruler
paths with this early b5 Bishop c5 one
of the active lines that like has it as
total it's a bit more based on active
pieces than some other reliance but it
also requires lots of their study of
concrete variations harikrishna played
like that it's interesting to note that
the pollen form is some yeah is hanging
the black cannot take it due to this
well-known technical trick attacking
both knives winning one of those however
after the capture black can take
interesting now the double attack is
answered by three to the eighth okay so
like saved his safe is ninth however
Queen c2 is a good move attacking this
night and destroyed so again it's a
renewed double attack but it does not
win a piece interestingly enough because
our the bond has night to before Queen
takes three takes vision pigs and now d5
and the bishop is strapped is the middle
of the board very nice now while also
cannot do much with a counter attack
like this as after details before the
night is immediately attacked so this
desperado want to capture on h7 is
actually the best why it gets the pawn
let me pause back yep the material is
equal now in fact I would also say that
the position is probably about equal
Black has got the bishop pair which is
nice but on the other hand this see porn
is not ideal it's currently bit backward
and doesn't do much in the near future
also blanks b6 Bishop is looking at a
very well defended hole and it's not
doing that much it's interesting to see
that harikrishna actually does not mind
to give up the full bishop pair we have
so too nice against two bishops and
these situations can be very favorable
for the bishops if the position is
opened up and the structure is gasps
well suited for for those long range
pieces however here things are not that
clear the white power structure is very
sound and it's not so clear what the
bishops are going to attack so even
though yeah I being a big fan of the
bishop pair I'm not sure yet how much
this is for black I think I would still
rather be black but I don't think he has
a huge advantage um I think both sides
played very reasonable
in the next couple of moves right put
this night on d3 which is kind of the
obvious square for it looking at
important squares and the the crisis in
this game is coming now when harikrishna
all of a sudden played H for attacking
on the King side we have to see that the
black king is not particularly well
defended and white has a threat his idea
is to take on g5 and then gain the e5
square so black cannot just play
whatever i'm just doing this again this
this and white yeah we'll jump into this
fantastic square and wind quite easily
yes the g5 porn is going to fall and
it's fantastic so he had to take check
Knight takes check now where to go now
with the king if you go back now like
that's still conservative came back
white will go here and this does not
look nice and there's the threat of 96
winning the game so probably a black has
to capture and this is extremely
uncomfortable the bishop on b6 does not
help Blackie at all the c6 pawn is weak
and all in all white is a lot better
actually black only had one good move
King g5 you have to step forward yeah
but this is not an easy decision chenine
every check and again what are you doing
are you going to take that pawn are you
going back the alternative would be king
g6 ignoring this pawn but this is
definitely going to favor white and it's
easy to see why something like g5 will
get rid of this pawn and then again if I
it would be a fantastic
the destination of light of the White
Nights so I'm on took this poll and this
is the right decision it is only yeah
putting black in a situation where with
the scheme on g4 you have to be
extremely precise if you make one
mistake you're just going to get
checkmated look aged one now that book
is lining up the next look is also close
King at five is the best move check
check and King back to the six this is
also fund and now very clever move by
Hari Krishna you just place look aged
six we have to note that why does upon
down but ok he's very active and has
threads all over the place now honey bun
has to play key to yourself this seems
to be the move that keeps everything
balanced white can attack of course like
this attending night h5 but it does not
seem to be decisive if black takes us by
the way chatters rook h7 now something
like that is no good king of seven is to
move but he played into at five and it
turns out that this move moves 39 with
lando no time on the clock loses the
games nine inch phone is the correct
move and it was played by Hari Krishna
the toughest move now would have been
King before it looks a little bit
suicidal but this would have been
actually not that easy for a while at
least there's chances to go wrong the
simple looking looking into for example
isn't directly winning you to Bishop
takes the form now White has a ton of
checks and it looks very threatening
like this but at the end Gentry is also
falling and why does through the down
in terms of porn count plus you have two
nights which is always going to be a
problem as to single nights cannot
change mate so this isn't so easy at all
right however after King info has a
winning move in roots III which isn't
extremely intuitive so not easy at all
it was move a would've bid move 41 so
hurry Krishna's would have had time to
figure that out still this is firm at
least a good practical chance of like
the move kingi fire forever when Ali one
plate leads to a direct check mate check
check takes check only move this and
that's it Black has no signal check and
the next move is rook one or look H
takes h3 checkmate so a tragic end of
this game Friday bond he played the
perfectly ok up to one specific point
where yeah he stepped on this on this
mind bass player here you have to go to
have several the other more king and
five seem to be or not seem to be worth
losing was losing so a win for Hari
Krishna here in this yeah indian indian
duel the next game i want to check
second to size of gamers when Bailey
alia not in this game we had a crease
Indian defense and the rising position
is something that we also see a quite a
bit from the Catalan so talking about
this structure white has given up the
bishop and the bishop on Air Force have
been taken but he is also limiting
blacks queenside play quite a bit this
Bishop is passive it's much less active
than the bishop on g2 in general and i
would say that why does quite finding a
prolate
very slightly better from in the game
centralization and activation of pieces
are pretty pretty normal looking white
wants to keep pieces on the board of 94
and black place f6 and f5 this is
actually I think quite a good idea the
knight on e4 was active and is pushed
back and the v5 square um yeah did not
prove to be all that much of a problem
like it's always able to hide for this
good addition he played King edge 80 and
c5 freeing himself finally on the dnc
files there are so many pieces of the D
file that this opposition of rook and
queen doesn't do all that much yeah tix
and just recaptures yeah maybe now with
the video click neither three maybe you
should have taken their just simplify
matters like this I think like is ok but
I like this a little bit more than the
game if you ask me he played this and
now alien off when to play Queen a8 I
always like this kind of battery
maneuvers it looks dangerous and there
is really some danger with black moving
to the night away he would attack f 3
and X rained all over 2g two so there
are some technical ideas and the
detectors and mad at six now was a good
move by our love and light now cannot
take only six because of the move Knight
g4 that threatens night except to check
and the capture on e5 winning material
as there is a huge pressure on the
diagonal Queen take me six doesn't work
why had to play king g one that was the
rightmost position t5 Queen
and Bishop t6 this phase of the game is
played well that both sides but we get
to a critical position soon afterwards
and I think it's here i'm not mistaken
yet here in this situation White has to
play a certain move it since one of
those cases where you have to check a
position and come to the conclusion okay
I have to play this exact move otherwise
it's not great and this is here 337 was
the right move and this is what when
really played Queen d7 make some sense
the queen is activated and also it's
looking a little bit as the black king
one point very important point is that
the move Knight f4 which was playing in
the game neglects the C 1 square and
okay black immediately could explore
that with a check and now white is in
some trouble already the normal move
look see one failed due to Quinn 56 and
wide screen here is overloaded if one
takes yeah it's a full book because it
makes you wanna check so something like
this should be played and then quits it
two wins of life quite drastic something
like this yeah will be a week for black
I can't take this first okay and then
he's going to win with Bishop night in
the attack okay that doesn't look good
so he played King edge too but this is
also not going to cut it the cause of
create oops so each form is impossible
to defend on
so that was a pretty substantial mistake
by friend maybe that night a form of him
yeah right now it's lost there's just
not much that that can can be done each
one gets taken and wide skin as yeah we
can in a way that cannot be repaired
that was a kind of a desperation
decision to take on defiled but check it
again it looks beyond repair the import
looks dangerous but black is just a bit
too quick here his threatening looks it
too and then the white king will be a
yeah I will not be surviving this so
good win by iron off played a solid set
up and then when many made a mistake
while the clock was ticking down a
tactical misjudgment Caproni okay so
alien off is on two out of two and he's
won the first round and this round as
well hi-low game to check is Magnus
Carlsen's game the run champion plays
right against Brad a quite a shake and
we got an ID off and can now place a
three yeah is that the reputation on the
night off I don't think so okay it has
been claimed already in the first round
by kayaking with wine against unleash QE
and to be honest I don't understand to
move at all I mean I understand the idea
to just bring something new we are just
try the new idea something that has not
been like analyzed to dance but I'm not
quite sure what a three actually does
one thing that a thought would be
interesting but was not played not this
time and not in the round before what's
g6 you are going to a dragon set up I
would really think that a 3 is a bit of
a useless move in the dragon I mean in
non-catholic scenarios a 3 looks
completely wrong and if you cancel short
what exactly is a 3 doing
I'm really not sure what towards the
ideas against the dragon but it wasn't
plate if I first played of course that's
not a bad mood are not saying that but I
just wonder then watch what happens I'm
to g6 yeah Calvin claims 95 interesting
choice the ninth-best square if it
worked or tactics is f 5 year often in
the night off if you look at this for
example the night and goes back to be
three because of this idea if it wasn't
for this t5 idea 95 would be great
because the night would actually return
to good squares or be free it is bad but
this is answered by g5 and black is fine
you know what should lose the night in
fact yet after something like this we
get a position that is quite comparable
to the game however the difference is
instead of Bishop e2 white has played a
three in the game and this is actually a
lot better in comparison for white we'll
see ya Seether there's a comparison a
three instead of Bishop e2 and why is
this better for why because of this move
played by cars flipped out by him it was
all part of the prep this is a good move
g7 is a text can play by the night and
neck cannot play the move g6 because all
of a sudden this room is going to work
we take c5 threatens to win the hook in
the corner and the natural rubber ring
right c6 failed due to the nice trick
19th d for chess with huge material or
this child for winning material
so it's a funny trick night XD for just
winning a bomb very nice that means that
after Queen g4 like actually has to take
the night and now wyd recaptures with
the Queen and I think this was an
excellent preparation by column not
because this position is all that
brilliant but it is a position that is
perfectly suited for his playing style I
will show you what I mean let's do two
moments you just have to do one thing
compare this Bishop with this bishop the
bishop on d6 will always be behind this
'if I've before pawns and will be
passive the bishop on this diagonal here
my wife is always go in to pressurize
black from the d5 square from the b3
square always putting pressure on x 7
and in general on blanks position it's
just a little bit better for white and
it's totally risk cream carbon is
excellent in those situations it's not a
huge advantage by any means but it is
very one-sided the computer actually
think this is equal which might be the
case in the long run if you have a
machine defended but for human player
notes it's really really uncomfortable
and I also think that the computer is a
little bit under estimating the
long-term long-term ideas I think white
is definitely for choice especially in a
real practical game also note that h4
was quite nice with the roof coming into
the game like that the other book is
also going to be used right from the
starting position yeah why does not need
to casually anymore that being said the
whole situation is not desperate for
black at all it's just a little bit
better for wide is going to probe do
little things
and see what happens in fact we come to
this situation here on news 13 where
carbon is up roughly 30 minutes and
still has this nagging pressure note
that what is important for practical
chef if you have a situation like that
were comparable to white ship you a
little bit better and the opponent does
not really have any active possibilities
in this situation it's often a good idea
to build up some clock advantage play
quickly use the fact that your position
is easier to play if you have an easier
to play position and you get the other
guy into town trouble often this will be
a huge factor the real time defending
such a position is a real pain so use
your yeah the simplicity of play that
you have used that to play quicker and
this is maybe you want to also happens
here a little bit wider shake is down in
five minutes which is not huge time
pressure but still he now plays 26 and I
don't understand it sorry he just gives
this bond and he does not have any
compensation for this maybe he just
miscalculated something I'm not quite
sure what exactly yeah move that kind of
makes some sense like maybe this one
maybe this was the idea but wyd can take
ya note this is ok not going to end can
check all that well checkmate tough to
say that this is an easy tactic taking
on g6 so I don't really believe he
overlooked that he played hookie sample
and now we have no you cannot take here
you can but white TS yet I don't think
you're over the bat that's also pretty
simple to see I don't know in the game
he just continued here Quincy 7 you're
taking on c2 isn't all that great hair
white swirl
get a text like that and this is also
still still quite weak yeah I'm sorry
Queen c7 was played and yeah why didn't
trade yeah the black king is potentially
a bit weaker and then I can slowly
improve and it's got a pawn now into
bucher pretty nice g3 making the King a
little bit safer and now Queen City want
a good move it's x-rayed a for looking
at d4 and the 10th rugby 3003 look at
six and after the capture c3 was a good
move looking to take the air for porn
after this and route takes inform what
is check did resign already it cannot
take your own be true as Queen Jeff is
going to be a disaster yes quite quite
clear black cannot go yeah to this okay
truly to Nate I can go to g5 and
something like that he's also going to
be decisive so he couldn't take on be
tuned so what a shakes only option would
have been to just retreat and wide world
can't ya just yeah will be two pawns up
and still have this excellent position
and he decided to probably save a little
bit of energy and just yeah throw in the
towel yeah a good game by columns in a
very typical game if you want to look at
a thousand game this is a slight
advantage probing around playing quickly
and then like made a mistake then what I
think an interesting preparation this is
right out this early in this kind of
position and I don't think it was a good
decision by water check to allow this
of course he probably 10 or maybe maybe
had anticipated that he played this
quite quickly and this I think is not a
good prep I mean maybe in the position
isn't bad but it's just the wrong kind
of position I think again this
particular player so we have three
designs of games the world champion is
on the scoreboard with the win battalion
off is leading the event with two wins
all of the first around so i hope you
enjoyed the coverage for the second
round i hope the sound was fine and
there is any sound is it ok guys thanks
for watching